congratulations Josh has it sunk in yet  no shot  not at all I don't even think I won it's  like crazy what are you shocked and how  close the jury vote was I was completely  shocked which jury vote surprised you  the most  what do you Cody I'm like what Cody said  that his deciding factor was the fact  that you were upfront and said to him I  don't like you yeah all right big money  come in have you thought about the first  thing you're gonna do with that money no  idea honestly an account in an account  in an account like I have no idea but I  do wanna I know that me Paul and  Krista's we plan to a world tour I'm  gonna stick to my word we're gonna  travel the world together but and get  back to my parents you know my parents  they don't want anything they're like go  start your life but I want to get back  to them yeah would you come back and  play again I'm give me six months and  I'll jump right back in pots and pans  and all  [Laughter]  [Music]  you